The question is, given a box and an image texture, how do the two get attached?
Given a location on the box surface, how do we find the corresponding location
on the image? This is potentially a tricky problem. Say we just try to use the
location in the world as our input. This won't work well, because our crate
could be transformed with rotations and scalings. It might undergo an explosion
that would change its shape. Any of these events would modify the world
position on its surface, making it hard to get to the same pixel location on
the image from frame to frame. This location problem is most commonly solved by
adding two values to every vertex. These are called UV coordinates. Just like
any other attribute attached to a vertex, these values are interpolated across
each triangle during rasterization. Every pixel fragment generated for the
surface will have these values available. Within the fragment shader these two
values are used to look up the corresponding pixel location in the texture. A
pixel on a texture is often called a Texel to differentiate it from a pixel on
a screen. For example on this face of the box we want to find a texel color to
use for this pixel. At this pixel the UV coordinate turns out to be U equal to
0.2, V equal to 0.7. Using these two values like coordinates on a map we can
look at the texel on the image and use this to modify the color of the surface.